[Music]
before we saw this video I just wanted
to mention that 89% of you who watched
this channel haven't yet subscribed so
if you enjoy the content please do us a
favor and hit the subscribe button with
that being said please enjoy the video
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter Theory in this video
we'll be discussing all ten of the
different types of dragons that were
either shown discussed or mentioned in
any of the Harry Potter and fantastic
beasts films and books as we know
dragons are giant winged fire-breathing
beasts that incite fear in the hearts of
even the bravest witches and wizards
they bear the potential to be extremely
destructive and they are even classified
as category X X X X X by the Ministry of
Magic this classification means that
they are known to kill witches and
wizards and are either extremely
difficult to or impossible to
domesticate we see or hear mentions of
dragons pop up constantly throughout the
books and films and they are an integral
part of the series the motto of Hogwarts
is even based around dragons as Draco
Dorman's noone qualms to tell on this
literally translates to never tickle a
sleeping dragon draco malfoy his first
name even translates to dragon in latin
dragons are everywhere so with dragons
being so prevalent in the series if you
are anything like me you've probably
asked yourself how many types of dragons
are there well you've come to the right
video let's dive into it
antipodean apply the antipodean o pillai
is a medium-sized dragon between two and
three tonnes that dwells and valleys the
dragon is native to new zealand but is
known to migrate towards Australia if
and when territory becomes scarce the
opal eyed dragon is considered by many
to be the most beautiful dragon and has
iridescent pearly scales and
multicolored pupil eyes eyes the opal
eye is not particularly aggressive and
is generally known to have a calm
demeanor however when the opal eye gets
hungry it can be bad news if you're
close by like most dragons the opal eye
breathes fire
uniquely produces a vivid scarlet flame
the opalized favorite food is sheep the
Chinese fireball the Chinese fireball
aka the lion dragon is a medium large
sized dragon between two and four tonnes
that dwells in all sorts of landscapes
the dragon is native to China and
primarily it resides there
the Chinese fireball is known to be more
accommodating about sharing its
territory than some other dragons the
Chinese fireball is scarlet coloured
with smooth scales and golden spikes it
also has particularly piercing eyes the
fireball part of its name comes from the
balls of flame that it shoots out of its
nostrils Victor Krum notably faces a
Chinese fireball in the Triwizard
Tournament attempting to retrieve a
golden egg that it was protecting the
chinese fireball keeps trim with a
relatively modest diet of pigs and
humans the commonwealth green dragon is
a native dragon to wales it is
relatively subdued as a breed and preys
mainly on sheep and small mammals as it
prefers not to interact with humans the
welsh greens distinct color allows it to
blend in well with the grass of its
homeland it has an easily recognisable
and melodious roar and jets out fire in
thin streams fleur delacour
face this breed of dragon for the first
task of the Triwizard Tournament in 1994
she enchanted the creature into a
magical slumber to retrieve her golden
egg hebridean black the hebridean black
is the other native dragon to Britain
and is more aggressive than the common
Welsh green the black is large rough
scaled and with razor-sharp ridges along
its back it can grow up to 30 feet long
and has glaring purple eyes the
hebridean black resides in the hybrids
islands in Scotland and can usually be
found there feasting on deer and cows
hungarian horntail
i'm sure you guys know this one already
the hungarian horntail is widely
considered to be the most dangerous of
all dragon breeds and harry famously
faces one in the Triwizard
tournament the horntail is enormous and
has a lizard-like appearance along with
bronze horns spikes that protrude from
its long tail and yellow eyes with
vertical pupils it is known to have one
of the longest fire-breathing ranges and
can scorch you from fifty feet away the
hungarian horntail was also used in
hogwarts as one of the guardians of the
cursed vaults Hagrid had this to say
about dragons in general oh don't worry
about him Harry they're seriously
misunderstood creatures although I have
to admit that horntail
is a right nasty piece of work the
Norwegian Ridgeback goes by another name
Norbert
the Norwegian Ridgeback is a rare breed
of dragon and resembles the horn tail in
a lot of ways the main exception is that
the ridgeback has black bridges on its
back and a browner quality to its scales
the ridgeback is known to prey on large
mammals and even water mammals and it
was reported in 1802 that a Norwegian
Ridgeback was seen carrying a whale calf
in its mouth off the coast of Norway in
the series Haggard receives a Ridgeback
egg from a stranger in a pub after the
egg hatches Hagrid names him Norbert
Hagrid eventually has to give up Norbert
and gives him to Charlie Weasley who
takes him to the romanian dragon
sanctuary Peruvian Viper tooth the
Peruvian Viper tooth is the smallest of
the dragons but is extremely dangerous
and highly venomous the average adult is
approximately 15 feet in length which
compared to the 50-foot horn tail is not
particularly large however the Viper
tooth was once a substantial threats to
wizard kind as they were reproducing at
an alarming rate
they are smooth scaled with copper
colored black Ridge markings short horns
and long fangs the Viper tooth usually
eats ghosts and cows but it has been
expressed that they have a particular
craving for humans romanian longhorn the
romanian longhorn is a medium to
large-sized dragon with dark green skin
and two golden horns it is a native
dragon to romania where Charlie Weasley
works for the Romanian dragon sanctuary
the Romanian Longhorn is particularly
muscular
and it's horns jet straight out of his
head like a bull it's a particularly
intimidating looking dragon but it isn't
overly aggressive the Romanian longhorn
population is relatively low because
their horns have such a high value this
is supported by the chocolate frog card
which states the following the horns of
this dragon are highly valued as potion
ingredients and as a result its numbers
are fallen in recent years Swedish short
stout the Swedish short snout is a small
to mid-size dragon with silvery blue
skin and scales the short snout
primarily resides in uninhabited
mountain ranges and rarely comes into
contact with humans Cedric Diggory
notably faces the short snout in the
Triwizard Tournament where he
transfigures a rock into a dog
distracting the dragon this allows him
to successfully to retrieve the golden
egg that the dragon was guarding the
short snout is particularly dangerous
dragon as it is agile fast and able to
produce a flame that is said to reduced
timbre and bone to ashes in mere seconds
in the Goblet of Fire the short snout is
shown as yellow which contradicts the
novel which depicts it as silvery blue
Ukranian iron belly the Ukrainian iron
belly is a monster of a dragon and the
largest breed it is stated that the
Ukrainian iron belly can reach a weight
of up to 6 tons which is at least 2 to 3
times the weight of most of the dragons
in this list it has metallic gray scales
deep red eyes and long vicious talons
the iron belly is slow but dangerous
than the less as its sheer mass causes
it to crush anyone and everything that
it lands near the last range Fault
inside of Gringotts was guarded by
ukrainian iron belly and was
subsequently set free by Harry Potter in
1998 during their escape from Green Gods
the iron belly is mentioned in the
fantastic beasts films as well when Newt
mentions to Jacob that he worked with
iron belly's during the first world war
with the ten primary purebred dragons
out of the way is also worth mentioning
that there are two other unconfirmed
dragon breeds I haven't included them in
this list because there aren't enough
evidence to support their existence and
they are not mentioned in the fantastic
business of creatures these dragons are
the Catalonian fireball and the
portuguese long snout which appear in
the book dragon breeding
and profit a book which Hagrid I
shouldn't have borrowed from the
Hogwarts library the books description
reads as follows tried and tested tips
to help you brie dragons including the
old time favorite of brandy and chicken
blood every half hour from newly hatched
chicks one thing that can be said about
this book however is that it is very out
of date this is expressed by Hagrid when
he says the following well I've been
doing some reading got this out of the
library
dragon breeding for pleasure and profits
it's a bit out of date of course but
it's all in here perhaps the book is so
old that the Dragons mentioned above are
extinct either way as far as I know
these dragons are not accounted for
anywhere else it's also worth mentioning
that on occasion Dragons have been known
to interbreed
this results in rare hybrid dragons any
hybrid dragons would also not be
included on this list and that's it for
this video which dragon is your favorite
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]